howdy dowdy
can anyone
confirm
that you can see me
that'd be nice
excellent cool
yeah hi everyone um
i just i announced
that there would be a
ask me anything
for the 100k
and
why is there blank green screen sorry
what do you want me to do
um
yeah so so uh i've
i thought this would be a neat thing to
do
and sorry it's a bit spontaneous but i
had time and i realized i wouldn't have
time
so much
so many more times um yeah
thanks everyone for subscribing thanks
everyone for for being here
and
there's not really a plan for now
um
so
we'll just see maybe this is over after
five minutes or so but
in general it's ask me anything it is
not i'll answer anything but it's it's
uh don't you know
uh it's not topical
so i'm just i'm trying to i'm trying to
catch up
will there be more live coding sessions
in the future i hope so
i'm i'm not really sure i get less
competent as i age uh with respect to
coding um
so
but yeah i don't know if live coding for
some things it's good if you know what
you're doing and if the experiments
don't need a lot of time but inherently
in machine learning at some point you do
train and then you wait and then what do
you do with the live stream so
i i don't i don't know if if someone has
neat ideas of how to bridge the time
there
um
yeah maybe maybe projects where you can
do first the chunk and then let it train
and then the next day come back or
something like this i don't know
uh timitrosh asks do we need a phd in
a.i to get into industry no certainly
not
it might be a little bit
more difficult to get into a research
position
given that many people are doing ai phds
now
but also companies are looking
for them
but what's also always an option is that
you start as a software engineer in a
company and then just you you
essentially make friends with the
research team
and uh you just show them that you're
quite competent at research you know
however you get competent once they know
you are competent they'll probably want
you on on their team so if there's head
count
that's that's another another way to get
into the research in industry
did you know arsenal scored three what
ah no
sorry
why is there no minecraft background
i'll try to get one going um
your phd thesis
where are you working or planning to
work i work my phd thesis is done i'm i
do officially have my title
um i'm planning i'm working in zurich i
have a startup um in nlp
so
yay
most problems in deep learning boil down
to cross-entropy loss and gradient
descent this realization is very
demotivating due to the lack of
intellectual stimulus insights
well
yeah i mean you know most problems in
networking boil down to sending things
over over cables yeah it's it's true
that
at least the the current
paradigm is deep learning which means
it's gradient descent uh in large models
but there is still enormous creative
freedom on how you design the models how
exactly you use them or even to just
sort of uh
research what happens when you do these
very simple principles right it's it's
it's astounding very simple principles
uh very simple training methods paired
with
what is essentially quite simple blocks
of computation give this incredible
result and and i think that's
that's pretty cool you ah sorry that's
that's pretty cool in itself um
yeah so
i think it's even an improvement over
let's say you're in the in the svm area
of machine learning all you can do is is
svm
right there's not a lot of freedom but
now you can you can design models and
frameworks and systems and and
objectives
yeah
so i think i think it's rather than it
being
lack of intellectual stimulus actually
frees you up to do a lot more stuff
why sunglasses it's
so you ask this question of course
um
what are the things to be followed to
become a researcher in the ai field
whatever whatever look i can't predict
what's gonna happen this field changes
so fast
no nobody knows what's gonna happen so
it's probably best you just follow
whatever interests you most
and if it's a genuinely interesting
thing and you like to do it then there
will be a place for you to do research
on it
you know whether it becomes the exact
hype of the next years
yeah that's
that's just chance
cats or dogs um
cats probably
how long have you been studying ai
i don't know well
five years or so i really didn't know it
existed when i started bachelors and
then i sort of knew it existed when i
started masters
then i learned it during masters and and
then um
yeah i applied for a phd at that point i
still really didn't know what was going
on and only after
maybe two three years of phd i i sort of
knew what was happening
um
why sunglasses because it's so bright
what are you working on now
i'm a
i'm a i have a startup in nlp for
legal document understanding well you're
not supposed to say understanding it's
legal document processing right
what are you working oh sorry that was
it can you fix my bug yes of course
you missed uh
you you had a comma no on it like this
is
commas at the end of things in python
will ruin your code um if you forget
about them because it makes whatever you
whatever you have into a tuple um
and that's quite messy to find later
who do you think is better messi or
ronaldo
i have not
cared which ronaldo even i i don't know
i actually i watched soccer
when ronaldo was still pr playing um
but i have no clue
um
most problems in deep learning oh we
already had that what are your opinions
on me tubers
um
i honest i have never watched a v tuber
other than
looking up
what is a v tuber
if you know i i have no i have no basis
to complain since i'm wearing gimmicks
when making videos so you know they are
yeah
they're fine i guess whatever they want
to do
any tips
any tips could help in reading and
understanding research papers
not really it just i think it comes with
practice and understanding that
most people in their papers they they
sort of want to sound more
they want to sound better or
more
they want to sound more relevant than
they are so they'll frame
their work in very formal
you know prosaic ways and
you just have to keep in mind that their
ultimate ideas are going to be there's
like
very few ideas per paper
you try to read those out try to see a
little bit
um what's the real meat behind a paper
and
yeah the rest comes with with practice
are a and n's like real ns so our
artificial neural networks like real
neural
networks well in some ways they are in
other ways they're not
we've certainly come a long way from the
the real neural network um though i
think
even if you know the individual neurons
aren't like real neurons and and back
prop doesn't exist in the brain and so
on
the things that we learn about
distributed representations of data and
things like that um can can definitely
carry carry over from from either field
so even even though there might be sort
of the lowest layer has diverged there
are aspects of the emerging phenomenon
that might be quite the same
advice for undergraduate deep learning
researchers
if you're a researcher and you're an
undergrad you're already you're doing
fine like
when i was an undergrad i had trouble
avoiding walls if you're already a
researcher you know a good job that you
don't need my advice
favorite non ml book well i don't know
that's that's tough honestly i i'm not
much of a
of a book uh person
um
[Music]
so
i don't even have a favorite ml book i
like i can
i i know some but i've never read
you know an actual book
uh yeah so sorry no good answer on that
oh no i lost
i lost
ah i lost all of you i'm sorry i'm i i
will have to skip
some of the
some of the question if i've skipped
yours please
ask again the chat has just scrolled
down so i'll i'll do these ones
and then i'll go up if there are not
more ones i'm sorry
um is the ai field saturated
i don't know like
sure there is like super duper increase
in research papers and that seems
a bit saturated and also
there is sort of a lack of
big new inventions and
uh all of that but on the other hand
there are lots of products yet to be
built on these technologies uh so i
don't think necessarily the the field
that itself is saturated maybe
maybe the core research path we're on
right now is due for a bit of a
disruption a bit of a new paradigm a new
idea or soul
but you know
favorite movie
what do i know lord of the rings or
something i like lord of the rings good
movie good movie also fight club
pytorch versus tensorflow what's your
perspective just use whatever like
whatever makes you happy
uh bickering about bickering about
libraries and
bickering about libraries and
programming languages and so on is is
too often
not worth it use whatever solves your
problem
the easiest or or fits your situation
what do you think about prompt
engineering probably probably going to
become
important in the near future
i think we still don't understand
i think there are still a lot of tricks
in prompt engineering that we haven't
figured out quite yet
just because it's so young right
why do you think we focus on big data
and scalability instead of training
efficiency
is it just google i guess it it is
probably just google it's easier right
yeah it's it's it's way easier to just
add machines um
because
they have
money they have lots of money
and
as far as we can tell
um
scaling up gives you an almost
guaranteed improvement in performance
and
efficiency is harder because you know
the i don't know the people who designed
the core libraries like
cuda and and and blas and lopac
they already did a lot of efficiency um
built in and and sure we can we can make
things a lot more efficient but i think
it's just
it's easier to just scale up
especially if you're big companies
what are your advice and tips for
applying a phd in ai at eth do you need
to have publication record what is the
acceptance rate i i don't i don't know i
from the time i applied this has changed
a lot um
you know just try to
try to be as uh
as attractive as possible to hire
that's that's all i can say it's good if
you know people like it's good if people
in an institution already know you and
know that you are
capable and competent um
that helps but other than that just um
yeah look at
what their criteria are and try to match
that
publications are certainly good nowadays
it's it's astounding that you need no
you don't need them but a lot of people
have them
but it's not necessary
sorry oh the question by lucas continues
is it just google who steers the field
to big data as it's their business
politics yeah probably
um yeah also also
it's a competitive advantage right if
you're competing with
universities you can pretty easily pull
ahead by just playing to your your
strengths right so you just do if you do
research
where
universities or smaller companies simply
cannot
pay for it uh you're
essentially
you don't have as much competition
so
but also good things come from that i
mean
once someone i mean bert i guess was
considered large at the time and now
pretty much anyone can train bert at
home or for very cheap on aws so
not sure if if good or bad
but certainly they played to their
strengths right
do you know any other free compute
programs other than trc that could be
used trained bird roberta electra yada
yada
um
i'm i'm not sure so far i've had i've
had university resources which was
awesome
and
now i have company resources which are
awesome so i'm not i'm not in the
situation
for free compute
do you have innovative idea for agi
um
okay as as cliche as this sounds but
it's probably worth going through
like the 80s and 90s and 2000s
literature and try to see what people
did then but didn't have the compute
necessary to achieve
but it's it's i know this sounds schmidt
uber-ish but it's entirely possible that
ideas from then or or modifications on
them come back
and um
combine with the current things that we
know
and the current compute to to produce
really cool things not sure if that's
going to lead to agi but
certainly yeah
what app do you use in your pay-per-view
videos onenote
and obs to record
do you think data scientists should
learn docker cloud
it's overwhelmingly especially for
students
probably not right um so should should
is a big word i don't think you should
you should probably
learn
whatever
is required for you to do your work um
i am generally interested in all kinds
of technical things so
i
i learned docker i learned cloud whatnot
i learned
you know whatever i could get my hands
on just because i found it interesting
and sometimes that helps you right
sometimes you can write a better
experiment code you can
schedule your experiments more
efficiently yada yada because you're
more competent in some other thing but
it's certainly not necessary so if you
feel overwhelmed do not
learn technology
outside of the things that you have to
know
what are your routines for keeping up
with the state-of-the-art literature and
filtering signal from noise this is an
it's an eternal struggle i i
like i've never claimed to have the best
filter or anything i just look around
twitter reddit archive like the new new
releases there various newsletters blogs
and so on people posting stuff around on
discord and
whatever interests me i look at it but
there's there's too much stuff don't
on you know in your particular niche you
should be able to keep up otherwise your
niche is too broad um
so but that's that's sort of your focus
if you're a researcher but for the
general landscape
you cannot hope for more than just grab
bits and pieces from from everywhere so
yeah
would you have done a phd looking back
considering you're doing a startup right
now yes
i would have i enjoyed the phd i i've
never seen the phd as sort of a
a thing that i need to progress or
anything like this i don't i don't think
a phd is necessary for a for a career i
also didn't aspire to become an academic
i simply i did a phd because honestly i
didn't know what else to do
um
and having done it i absolutely enjoyed
the
the freedom and the fact that it placed
me like in the middle
of
this whole
happening in research in ai might be
that i have done it at the
been at the right place at the right
time but would totally do it again yeah
but not if not as a as a career move um
there are better ways to do career
ai generated meshes and textures based
on descriptions when
didn't know that was a thing i mean
cool
how do you see the movement towards
decentralization affecting the ml
industry
is there is there a movement towards
decent uh i think
if anything we see a movement towards
centralization with the
increased requirements in compute like
it's not it's not
it's not only
so
it's not only that the compute gets
centralized right like okay
you now can no longer do your thing on
your computer you need to use your
cluster and if you don't have a cluster
you go to google or aws not only is it
centralized in that but it goes further
it's now you don't even train your own
model you simply subscribe to language
model api or something like this so i
think
there is a centralization
centralization happening and
honestly i don't see something like
blockchain interfacing too easily with
machine learning because the two things
are are sort of
not only orthogonal they're kind of in
opposite directions um
and it's going to be interesting to see
interesting combinations of the two but
so far i see a centralization trend in
a.i
is math invented or discovered in
european
who knows um it's math invented
or discovered
i have i've no i have no clue i i think
math as as any other sort of science
is
is simply an up so in my opinion math is
an approximation
to the world so it's it's a it's an
approximate way of talking about the
world and i realize mathematical systems
are built up upon
their own axioms and so on and
in theory you could come up with any
mathematical system but ultimately we do
math
um
because we want to
understand and describe the world and
yes some people
some people are very much off in the in
in in abstract space and and completely
unrelated to the world but
i think we as
we by we i mean mathematicians humanity
keeps math reasonably close to reality
so such that my opinion is it's it's an
approximate description
of of reality in the same way as physics
is and the same way as biology is and
and so on
when will you do full review of open ai
codex i'm playing around with it um i'm
trying to to see what it can and can't
do and so on um
also there i think people haven't
haven't quite figured out yet
what the um
people haven't quite figured out yet
what what things are possible but
neither have i so yeah
um
when are you giving condi again it's
happening every
every wednesday and thursday at five
do you think rl is underappreciated
um
what do i no probably probably not it's
i think it's rl is appreciated quite
well for essentially
for essentially being random search
it's
it's retained its
rl is more like the
this idealistic idea that oh there's an
agent and it does nothing else then
learn from observation and uh reward
so
and i think this this captures
the mind of many people when they think
of ai
so i think it's appreciated quite well
um
your advice for ph applying for phd in
eth yeah just
try to match try to match the criteria
um it's good if you know someone that's
that
how to get into research as a beginner
i'm self-taught don't know what to do to
get into research
just
if you're if you're really a beginner um
i would try to just focus on a single
area like just um
pick an area that particularly interests
you like a sub sub subfield of ai and
just try to
get into that you might choose that a
bit smartly such that you know it's not
how do i build gpt3
uh
but you know any anything where you can
do
some things yourself then try to get a
good overview over that subfield
and and i think once you have that
you already have a lot of prerequisites
to understand the whole field
if you're a master student now would you
still go for a phd yes
definitely how much do you bench or
squat
i don't i've i've never done signal rep
max so i i don't know
bench maybe
i'm not good at that bench so maybe 60
kilo
squat i don't know 120
many areas of ml research are
fascinating so how do you decide which
research problem to work on yeah
so this is a combination of whatever
interests you and whatever do you
whatever you
think um
so what what interests you what you're
good at and what's you know possible
physically let's say given your your
resources
so it's a bit of a strategic selection
but ultimately you should go with what
you're what you're interested in
um because you know if it doesn't work
out at least you've done something that
you thought was cool because and
you know if you if you go for a topic
that doesn't interest you if it doesn't
work out then there's really nothing
good about that
do you think
no
i'm not
saying
saying these words
um no mood to get kicked off
you think weather forecasting will be
possible in the future
ah
no
you think we could create agi in this
lifetime
uh it depends on
how you define agi
i i have no i have no idea
for most definitions you'll probably
never reach it
you think having a phd is important for
pursuing research in ml no you can do ml
well completely without
having a phd
your opinions about the computer vision
lab i
have vaguely heard like i don't know
many people from there
so far looks looks neat looks cool
and they do interesting stuff graph
neural networks versus convolutional
neural networks
whatever fits your
probably every the
cnn is a special case of the gnn right
so
i don't know
if you like special cases go for a cnn
how can we call minimax algorithm is a i
or not sure
like we call if conditions ai so we
should also be able to call minimax
conditions ai
okay now i've uh
i've skipped a bunch of questions again
so the chat refreshes
periodically and i'm kicked out i'm very
sorry if i skipped your question
um
what for is your green background to to
to to project stuff on it i can
do i have filters here filters um
effect
probably
chroma key no
there we go
better
why capsule networks didn't go further
because it's a
it's a good idea but it's
it doesn't
like
there's a lot of magic and whenever your
your model needs magic um there's just a
small chance that it's going to work but
probably not um
so
this one
didn't
plus it's it's computationally at least
the way it was formulated at the
beginning it's computationally not
not really nice to current hardware
how have you learned the math for ml
you pick it up as you go like i don't
think it's worth
learning all the math there is and then
going into ml just go into ml
look at what's the math required to
understand the things that i need to
understand and then learn that area of
math
so
math is too vast to try to
pre-learn it
did you ever do you ever talk with lex
friedman not yet
not yet
divided looked at something
ah sorry chat no
okay this is this is too fast for a
single human to follow sorry
um
where were we
yeah i'm totally i'm totally sorry for
for skipping for skipping questions
i'm
i'm um overwhelmed if you want i need i
need some i need some sort of automatic
model to
answer the questions for me no
um
do you think love will save the world
that's a legs thing no
that is a lex thing totally totally
um
can you share your thoughts on how one
comes up with research problems or
topics
even smartly throwing spaghetti at a
wall and seeing what sticks may fail or
bear fruit yes
it's a science in itself i guess and
technically
uh
the senior people in research should be
able to help you with that so
this i think mostly comes with
experience from research in that you
have to develop a taste for
what ideas are
in the reach of the current state of
knowledge so are not known yet but
within reach and also likely to be
possible
this is way harder to do if you're new
to the research field if even if you're
super duper competent this is
a bit of a taste that you acquire over a
career in in research so try to
maybe ask or ask around uh people who
have been around for longer
um
or try to study
papers
of the past and and sort of try to
estimate what kind of steps they made
over previous work and then you can get
an idea of how far you can look ahead
over the current edge of knowledge
should i pursue prompt engineering sure
if you're if you if you like it um
that's
i mean it's it's it's a cool new topic
right
uh what's your favorite chai
i i
with milk
is that is that a is that a thing or do
all chai have milk
i'm
not exactly sure
um
did you ever consider going to a big
tech company to do ar research google
openai facebook i i was a part of google
as a research consultant and
an intern during the phd and it's it's
definitely a cool place uh to do
research
um
now i've decided
that i'd rather do a startup
it's a different climate
it's a different
climate to be in a big corporation or or
a small one
um
all of them have their advantages and
disadvantages
uh
yeah that's
it's mostly a matter of taste and and
you know experiencing both things i
think is is is nice so if you've done
one maybe give the other one a shot
um
have you come across research regarding
data set size versus data set quality
i think there is i'm not sure if someone
or or if there's uh
a lot of research looking at this
specifically but
um for sure we we see that both are both
are quite important so
you
you know like these language models they
oversample
corpora that they know or qualitatively
you know high quality so you can make up
um in a certain
in a certain manner for lack of size
with quality or possibly vice versa
and
there is research on these sort of
uh
adversarially created data sets where
they create the data points in such a
way that you only need like one data
point per class right so they sort of
condense the data set into single data
points and then that's your training set
like 10 data points for 10 classes and
then still the classifier generalizes so
that
gives a hint that um if your data is is
qualitatively
quite high it can replace size but
of course that's an artificially
contrived example so
i've come across research like this but
i don't think there's a definite
answer as to how important each of the
factors are
what is the best way to get started with
using transformers
well
i don't know go to hogging face do a
tutorial
um
this is all possible in collabs now so a
browser is probably all that all that
you need
what framework do you suggest for
distributed or parallel inferencing for
sd based object detection models on
nvidia gpu
i've i have no idea i i've never done
object detection in uh inference mode or
anything like like i've never done
object detection beyond research so
don't i'm a really bad person to take
advice from here
in your opinion is neurosymbolic bs
probably not right probably there's
something
to it because if you
say if you introspect your own head
you you clearly
see
that you yourself are
sort of manipulating symbols
right also the fact of how we program
right we manipulate variables and so on
um we developed programming languages
to also conform to our own thinking
patterns and patterns and so on so i
definitely think that something symbolic
is going on in the brain and
um
i've no
i have no idea whether that is an
illusion and it just arises from neural
networks doing their thing or whether
the brain's architecture has something
built in to
support that
and we should also augment
artificial neural networks by something
like this i i don't know but it's
certainly not it's certainly not bs
uh
yeah i the question is whether it arises
naturally and then appears to the
thinker as symbolic
or whether there are fundamental
structures that you need in order to
enable this symbolism in
a what is essentially distributed
hardware
leticia is here nice crossover hi
letizia
um
any advice to non-ml people for doing ml
no you're not you're not too far behind
like
ml changes so fast nowadays
uh that if you're a non-ml person you're
not very far behind ml people
that is if you are working with the
current
deep learning based systems and so on if
if it comes to like if you're doing
you know class classifiers from psychic
learn things like this xgboost and so on
then you probably want to get
reach out
to a person who has been doing this for
a long time
and get some advice from them
how was your application process for phd
i
did my master thesis with the
professor that
ended up hiring me for a phd so the lab
already knew me and they had openings at
that point um
so it was relatively smooth
and it was
just before the big the big boom so
i think had i been later um i might not
have been necessarily selected or at
least i would have had uh severe
competition whereas i i don't think i i
had like the circumstances were
the circumstances were very
uh fortunate for me
i have to say
um do you recommend going from a
bachelor's to phd directly what do you
think about eu academia
i mean
if you're looking for an academic career
or so on it
sure
it's the american model right to do
bachelors and then and then phd
i don't know sometimes it's not possible
like here at dth it's it's not
necessarily possible there is a special
program fast track phd
but
in essence you do need a master's to get
into a phd it depends on your in your
school
um yeah
what's your favorite optimization
technique um
out of
adam
um it used to be rms prop
because i did like at some point i did
like
three consecutive projects where always
rms prop would be a little bit better so
i was like rms prop is the best always
but yeah i like
just throw something at it and see what
see what happens you can't you can't
really go wrong with with applying adam
um and doing a little bit of tuning for
a
learning rate
um yeah
that's that's already the heuristic like
try a bunch of learning rates
i've never used genetic algorithms in in
any serious way so
um
okay chat refreshed again sorry from a
scale of zero to ten how much did you
suffer during your phd
well there are definitely
there are definitely um
there are definitely times when it gets
more
more more strict like conference
deadline times and so on
um
things when you're stuck times when your
stuff doesn't work
though i have generally enjoyed uh the
phd so
i i don't want to complain yeah that's
that's that
do you think fairness and bias in ai is
important
is as important as we think now why do
we expect ai to be unbiased if every
intelligent being is biased
well yeah okay that i guess you can you
can write an entire essay about this i i
do think um
fairness and bias research is definitely
warranted
and uh important
uh because there
like there are many
there are many
problems with this i i think
you know
since we're not doing ai just out of
joy i guess maybe the researchers are
but ultimately we want to build tools
that make our lives better and you do
expect from a tool
that it works in a certain way that is
reliable that it is um you know sort of
works as advertised right and
in this case
you should be at least aware if there is
some sort of a bias in the tool right if
there's a product
that some company sells
you know
it's it's good if it if it was
unbiased in all ways but at least you
should be aware if it was and so on so
you know with respect to that i
definitely think this is this is
important i do i do think that the
fairness aspect might be
a bit
overhyped in the sense that i see a lot
of papers that simply reframe whatever
they're doing in the language of
fairness or or de-biasing or something
like this
and um
in hopes of getting their papers
published because it's kind of a hype
topic right now
and i also
think there are there are a lot of
um
there are a lot of
i don't know
pointless things done down there or yeah
things like this but i definitely don't
think it's not important that's what i
would like to say
um yeah but sometimes i wish that that
community was a bit more
uh
like a bit more sober a bit more neutral
takes on things
rather than
the very opinionated takes that a lot of
these papers tend to have
um
uh
wire transformers better than fully
connected networks
well
they're not
they're they're probably better for some
things and
and then the mixers came back and and
whatnot it seems
that
the actual architecture might be less
important than the fact that you have
lots of parameters and
somehow shuffle the data around
um
yeah
oh conor is here thank you conor um
thanks a lot
this this yeah
people who don't don't oh sorry connor
is a henry a ai labs if you don't if you
don't know henry a lapse you should
definitely also subscribe
uh there i think um
we we we complement
each other
uh quite a bit
there and in fact there's probably space
for
a lot more of us youtubers in the uh ai
space because there's just so much stuff
like
i think um
conor would agree we can't we can't
possibly keep up with everything that's
happening it's crazy
um
our transformers computationally more
complex than convolutional models yes
um
i mean you can you can you can debate
you know which one uses more compute and
more parameters but just from a
perspective of
of what you need to do in a convnet you
it's simply a linear operation with
fixed weights and in a transformer you
first have to produce the weights uh to
do the forward propagation you have to
produce them in a dynamic way so
that's like one more step
that you need to do in each layer
yeah
do you think that deep learning
architectures for graph processing have
a future yeah sure i mean
um
it's probably a hardware constraint a
little bit right now for graph
processing
because
it just doesn't lend itself
a lot to current matrix multipliers that
expect to have sort of very rigid
structure tensors
but a lot of problems are graph
structured and not easily
structured otherwise like as tables or
images or sequences or whatnot so
definitely
graph processing
remains very important
do you have tips to address burn out in
ml
uh
no
um chill um
i think f fomo is fomo is big in in ml
because there's so much
stuff happening right
and um
yeah
just relax like
if if you've ever if you've ever
shut down for a week or something you
realize that you know you're still
alive and new things will still keep
appearing um even though you've missed a
bunch of things
so
you know slow down
and do your thing
that's
probably a good
things
who disliked the video who disliked the
video
it's fine it's fine it's cool
dislikes are good
i like the dislikes like i youtube
discusses always to remove the dislike
button
i enjoy the dislike button even like on
my videos this is the best signal um
you know sometimes i think i did a good
job with this video i did a bad job with
this video
but
you know you see it the likes are not as
much an indicator as the dislikes the
dislikes are like the best indicator of
whether or not i'm doing good job and
so i appreciate everyone
who clicks the dislike button if they
are unhappy with the with the results
um do you think there hasn't been
research
do you think why do you think there
hasn't been research into better deep
learning initializations that allow
faster conversions there there is
there's like massive research into
initializations it's still ongoing uh
but there is a lot of research
into into initializations like
yeah um
are you into crypto i like crypto like i
like the idea
of of crypto um
yeah
it's a cool topic
it's uh
i'm not sure
like
yeah because you instantly want to
combine it with ai but i don't see a
straightforward way and yeah other than
please pay me for my
computer or my gradients or something
like this
who knows
um
12 dislikes within seconds thank you
thank you
do you
like rusty no i oh okay i
i don't like
potatoes too much
um
yeah
except if they're like small and and in
a frying pan
but i'm not
i'm not a big potato
fan
it's a so here is here's the the thing
like the these
a lot of these traditional foods
people like oh this is a traditional
food of this in this area it's just the
famine foods it's just whatever the
people during the famines
had left to eat right so
like oh the potatoes here are really a
national dish like no you just you had
you you had nothing else like
there is other food now i'm not limited
to
starch ball
well in any case sorry sorry if uh like
yeah
and of course i mean i like i like
i'll eat rusty i will enjoy it um if it
is served to me i would not necessarily
cook it myself
how does your ideal day look like in
terms of being productive i asked myself
i ask myself this every single day and i
constantly fail so you know ideally
i get some work done
i get some sports in and i do something
for the channel every day that's sort of
the
ideal day
and uh i don't i don't always like
things come up and so on i don't always
get to do it but i try
what do you find the most awesome in a.i
i think it's
just i think it's quite cool
that the barrier to entry
is low right in general for computer
science topics um the barrier to entry
is so low
like sure you cannot train gpt 3 at home
but
for many things you need a laptop and
that's it right you can learn
you can do research you can participate
by simply having a laptop and and that i
find something extremely cool because in
many other research fields this is
completely out of question you cannot go
into synthetic biology
uh with a laptop i mean you can but you
know good luck
uh yeah
so yeah what's your favorite ml
technique what do i know
um
no idea probably logistic regression
i mean you just take whatever solves the
problem and that probably solves the
problem most of the time
um
can you cook sushi yes
how ai hardware should be
large lots
good and cheap food for masters and phd
students here the university mensa has
the cheapest food
um just saying
do you work now yes i well
i try
what do you think about kaggle uh i
think it's a it's a cool
concept i know that um very often caglar
kaggle solutions are
quite over fit to the
particular problem but i see that more
as a failure of the competition
of a competition
proposers than the the competition
solvers so i think if anything kaggle is
cool and we need to train the
the competition hosts better
you cannot train gpt3 at home how much
would you bet on that
um
yes
if you if you don't know yet look up
look up lucas's homebrew nlp project
uh
they'll be able to train gpt3 at home
quite quite soon
uh so it's on github it's clash look
homebrew nlp
what is your preferred operating system
oy okay um
for
for phones
android
uh because
i'm not sure if the iphones have widgets
by now or so on but android is just it's
more
sympathetic to me the ios is just too
too restrictive um
like i get it to streamline things but
it's too much
um
and then for
computers i use i use mac os
and uh
yes i know i know that's not really
popular um
but
as a like it just works like okay i
haven't used linux for a while
but
it just it's it's a really good ui
it just works and i have a unix shell
so
yeah
i can i can do my my coding and all in
the terminal
and i have a ui that works for
everything else and
yeah that's i'm happy with that for
servers i i prefer something like uh
like ubuntu just because i know it i
know where where things are there
so
yeah share your vim or cfa okay i will i
will i will share my uh vmrc file some i
can give an introduction to it in in
some video it's true
if your startup fails would you consider
moving to silicon valley no why why i
have been
i've been in california a bunch of times
now why would anyone live there like i
get that in something like the 90s this
had an appeal but now it's like the
state is
super duper
dry
it's burning all the time
there's giant there's like a risk of
earthquakes constantly um they have
rolling blackouts because they're too
many people
uh their farmland is degrading heavily
so it's not like
they're
they're gonna be this ooh where the the
farm of the nation for very long anymore
um
they've like giant problems with
homelessness
and where they haven't they're the the
the prop the cost of living is
so high if you live like in san
francisco or or in the bay area i don't
i don't get
why people still go that like if you're
there you're established and so on like
sure but
actively going there
like
i think there are
just just quality of life wise uh better
better options even if you say you want
to go to like the center of what's
happening in tech
there are probably better options
available
uh how do you go through cbpr and
nurip's submissions and identify quickly
what papers matters i don't like
conference
okay well submissions are different
submissions are a different thing but
certainly accepted papers are they're
just out of date like
they're just they're like half a year
old like who cares
can nlp automate bureaucracy yes it can
i mean some
well
i'm
building a startup based on that premise
so
are there any significant foundational
works in agi yet
i don't know it depends on what you
consider agi
who knows no idea sorry like probably
probably a
significant work will already be
defining agi in a correct way
um
i'm not sure you can consider everything
we're doing now
uh significant or foundational to it
is a t5 optimization a good thesis topic
for a master's degree
depends
um
so
depends on you know which lab and what
you're trying to do after
um
if if you're if you're aiming for like
certainly it's it's a good topic right
it's cool topic you can do something
right and you can you can go and
you can say here's a bunch of stuff i
found that make a difference and now i'm
x much faster or better or something
like this
if you have the compute available sure
um
you have to be be careful what you want
to do after
if you want to go into like a phd and
you want to go to a professor that
requires
that sort of so some professors they
like their students to be competent in a
more theoretical or mathematical way so
you'll have to see that in your thesis
somewhere you demonstrate a little bit
that you're not just like a practical uh
person that that hacks around
but that's that's pretty much all i have
to say
um please suggest a good research topic
bandits band like they don't die bandage
research does not die i don't get it but
you know
um
i'm hearing computational intelligence
more these days what's your opinion in
it sure
you mean other than you mean instead of
ai
sure i mean
it's probably a more descriptive a
better better description of what's
going on
rather than
artificial intelligence computational
intelligence because artificial could
also mean that like frankenstein is is
franken sorry frankenstein's monster
is also artificial intelligent
what was the homebrew link again
like it is a chinese repo sorry
it's uh it's it's on github it's or you
can on our discord we have a channel for
homebrew nlp
and the discord link should be somewhere
in the
description
um
yeah
80k dollars budget on the labs a gpu
system or spend it on cloud
if you have the opportunity for
if you have the opportunity for a local
machine and
you use it continuously it's probably
better to get a local machine if you can
manage it right you also need to
calculate that you have to actively
maintain it um
yeah but the costs are are way cheaper
if you have it locally
sorry
um
sorry uh
c plus plus for machine learning or just
learn a lot of python
you know
yeah again programming languages i don't
care but right now it's probably
way easier for you if you do learn
python it's not
it's not a hard language that i mean it
is a hard language don't don't get me
wrong i
so like uh
really understanding the object model
and and things like i don't know like
when late binding pulls and and exactly
what order things are resolved and so on
like there's a lot to learn
in python
but
the the level you need for doing machine
learning it's pretty easy to learn so
and and it will be
it will be
useful rather than trying to stick to c
plus not
not you know not the least because
everyone else's code is in python and
you'll be able to just copy
that of course retaining the appropriate
license notifications
any tips for someone getting into legal
tech
wanting to apply
and machine learning data to legal
problems should i focus on nlp anything
less obvious that i should know apply to
our startup um
no i mean other than that um
you know just domain knowledge is
important understand what your data
understand what you're doing so if
you're a tech person try to
team up with legal people
because they'll save you it'll save you
a lot of of headaches of course
yeah
did you do any work relating to biology
in your time at eth
um
no i have i've i've
taken a bunch of life science courses
in my bachelor's at the university of
basel
i also before that i did a year of
studying uh human medicine so
i have some i have some background
in biology uh but i've never done any
research in it
uh but i know it's a cool cool new
upcoming topic
yeah
do you have guilty pleasures or are you
just studying or working all day yes i
waste i waste a lot of time
watching
youtube videos on
whatever
um
today i wasted like
an hour just watching casey neistat
videos
uh
or i watch videos about urban planning
or something like like this like
i i was i waste time just as anyone else
does so
like
yeah
um
what do you think about microsoft
brainwaves crypto mining
sounds legit
is this legit
i mean this might be legit i don't even
know i don't even know at this at this
point
do you think we can reach aiba gradient
descent or do we need new learning
algorithms well
in gradient descent it
certainly might have its part right it's
a good optimization algorithm for
for neural networks so uh
yeah
um
who are your top three ai researchers i
you know like
schmidt uber has this new blog post
where he calls look how
lbh
i just thought that's a cool acronym
like lbh
uh but i don't i don't know i don't have
favorite uh favorite researchers um
you know there are many more than three
that do cool work
do you play any games i i
used to
i used to play games um
i no longer have time for playing games
so yeah
could you upload this ama on your
channel i haven't said anything
outrageous so far so i actually might
you know it's always a bit yeah a bit a
bit with the live things especially when
i show my screen i never know like have
i
typed something into my browser and then
an auto suggest
had like some search from i don't know
when where i was wondering hmm how
like how does this very gory
uh thing work or something
so you never
you never know
uh
yeah but given that this is is just this
i might
um
sorry
why is genetic algorithms not more
popular
well i
think it's well first of all it's not
suited to
the hardware we have and i don't mean
just gpus genetic
algorithms need
super duper duper massive parallelism
because usually they happen in
populations of living beings with
i don't know thousands or millions of
individuals at the same time recombining
uh developing with different
pressures from the environment and so on
and and that is just not going to happen
on
a computer that essentially does
uh
sequential uh computations or or minimal
parallelism even on a on a
gpu um
do you always wear glasses yes they're
they're stuck yeah
are you still active in asphalt set what
sports do you do else i'm yes i'm still
active
um
that's that pretty much covers my sports
needs at the moment
um
other than that i just lift sometimes
lex asks what's what is your meaning to
life i have no idea no clue
what is the story of the big sunglasses
um
i don't know i just
i thought i'd wear
them and
now people ask that question and i think
it's funny that people ask the questions
so i keep wearing them
um
why don't you use nightbot in your chat
i don't know what nightbot is
um
i am
terrible at
tech
i guess
what university did you graduate i have
a bachelor's degree
from the university of basel in
switzerland
and i have a masters and a phd from eth
in zurich
[Music]
what do you think of the learned hyper
parameter optimizer paper
and why does it get zero news coverage i
have not heard of it maybe because it's
gotten zero news
news coverage but usually just just
usually i don't know the paper but
usually the
metal learning
frameworks and so on
they
sort of
they shift the problem right they shift
the problem from optimizing a problem to
optimizing the optimizer and usually
they
run into the same problems when
optimizing the optimizer and it happens
to work for the papers or the techniques
they look at but then very often
the trade-off
of using such a system aren't worth it
because they often don't work as well as
advertised plus you still have uh the
problem
of having to now
optimize
or hyper parameter search inside of your
optimizer
even if the papers say you don't have to
do that you
quite often do
do you think sanskrit is good for ai i'm
not sure what what you mean like
to research on sanskrit or
i'm not
i'm not sure about the question have you
been in poland i have been in poland yes
i i
have visited poland before
cool country
very
oh
uh there there's sort of a there's also
a bit of a
like
i experienced the polish as being very
uh proud of of poland or being being
polish and and and in general they have
they think yeah
polish things are cool and you know that
it gives it gives the
gives the people a
i don't know a nice
a nice
attitude because they're
well they're in poland so
they're a bit you know already a bit
happy about that which is cool
what do you do for your day job um
i am a i yeah program mostly
for
uh my own startup
what do you think about geometric deep
learning
well
given that haven't we haven't we just
released like a giant street talk
episode about is this
no am i saying too much here no we have
right
yeah it's i mean it's it's it's
certainly certainly cool like this um
this pushing
pushing it's it's it's time we we push
the deep learning to to new modalities
and so on be that graphs or uh be that
you know other manifolds and and whatnot
um there's an entire problem space out
there that is not accessible by the
classical methods of just assuming
euclidean uh geometry continuous flat
spaces and so on and um
therefore yeah i'm i'm a big fan
how much of group theory should be known
for entering geometric deep learning
again it's uh i would i would
i would recommend you go read the
machine learning papers and then you see
what math is required to understand it
and then you go read the math rather
than trying to go learn all about the
math before enter a machine learning
field
that's probably more efficient
have you been in greece
probably
probably as a kid
um
i've been a long time father thank you
for a contribution thank you for uh
being a follower mike in your opinion
what do you think the next big thing
deep learning will be
um yeah if i knew right um
i have i haven't i've no id i can only
speculate as as much as
all other people can speculate
who can tell what the next next
if we knew we'd do it right so it's
probably going to be something rather
rather unexpected
um
i have no idea
like there are many people who who tell
you they know but
i'm not i don't
i don't believe them
uh don't want to be a professor but love
researching should i go for a phd yes
i mean you know
whatever
um whatever is enjoyable
to you i think
this is just my personal opinion i think
people
optimize too much for a career people go
like oh i need to do i need to do this
masters and i need to do the phd because
then i will
do this and this
um
you know life changes and and plans
change and and your interests change and
so on so i think you're unless you have
an extremely clear plan since you're
five years old
you're probably better off
just doing
whatever you're interested in
um sure have a bit of foresight and so
on but
if you're thinking should i do a phd or
not if you
like research if you like the phd life
um
i can tell you it's sometimes stressful
it's rather alone so it's not like you
work in as tight teams as an industry
and if you find a good advisor that
you know you click with um
certainly that might be something for
you but also industry has has appeals
and and there are
positions in industry where you can
still do quite a bit into the researchy
direction
um do you think consciousness and ai
will occur in our lifetime
awesome
how would you how would you know
right
like if if you propose a if you
like we need a better test probably for
consciousness
it would be surprising given that we
don't even understand our own
consciousness
like in
intelligence is probably easier than
consciousness no because intelligence
you know we we sort of measure
intelligence with oh
which tasks can you solve how fast can
you solve these like tasks or new tasks
how much can you transfer knowledge
uh how much data do you need for new
tasks and so on in consciousness we
don't even have a clue how to measure it
right um yeah
why is self-driving so much behind in
europe
is it i don't know i don't know whether
it is um
probably because
europeans generally are not as risky
there is also probably more
regulations
such that it it
the outlook of developing a working
self-driving system isn't as bright as
in other places because
say you develop one
you would have to
probably develop it to a higher safety
standard
than in other places and once you have
it at that standard
you it would take a lot longer for
the
society to sort of um
to sort of match up with what you're
doing
right
um i'm gonna go for like 10 more minutes
or so uh if that's if that's fine
um
what's next for the channel what will
take you to one million
i don't honestly like i'm i'm not i'm
not i'm not uh
um i don't plan on on on on
i should say
stopping or anything like i i am
doubtful that will reach a million i'd
be super happy if that happens um
i'm i'm also pretty happy if it just
stays at the
at the
um
if it stays at the size it is or if it
grows as it has grown now this is this
is fine i enjoy this
independent of how many people are are
watching or
how
how big it becomes
how often did you think of quitting your
phd
quite
quite a number of times um i think
that's a common experience though
and and then you think like well what
else should i do
you continue
uh
can you please tell me the roadmap to
learn deep learning in two weeks
that's a good question
um
hmm
i
i have no i have no idea do i probably
do do do a bunch of tutorials in
in computer vision in in nlp
in reinforcement learning
if you're if you're fast and pick up
stuff fast then you'll see
sort of the principles
what's your view on the machine learning
job market in zurich
out of google is it really mostly
ti finance reporting disguised as ml
probably i have never had to
um apply in zurich though i am now an
employer so i would be interested in
that in the answer to that question as
well
how do you organize your machine
learning project i don't i'm a mess
are you a believer
in in what
how much can you bench i don't know
uh probably
60 kilos or so i'm not not too good at
benching
is jax a good framework to start
learning deep learning sure
i think jax is doing fine
um
[Music]
yeah um sorry
his picks to picks or pix2pix hd still
the best approach for this tasks or
their new approaches
i i don't know i've i've lost the
overview over what's best like
what
what is best in papers and leaderboards
is often not what's actually best in
practice you you just need to try out
stuff
uh see what other people are doing
and that's probably the only way you
figure out what's really best and
not necessarily from papers
um
so like papers can give you
ideas and and new methods to try out
but it still comes down to you just
apply things to your problem and see
what is best
consciousness prior versus general
intelligence which one do you think is
more plausible and achievable
i you get depends i don't know it
depends again on your specifications of
what these what these things mean um i
am
like
certainly you need some sort of
prior built in or not you need but if
you do you probably make your life a lot
easier learning stuff so
yeah i'm not opposed to not opposed to
building in priors especially also given
that the priors you as a human have
aren't perfect
right so
that already signals you that you don't
necessarily need perfect priors in order
to um
in order to
be able to to to to build a system that
at least displays human level
intelligence
so yeah
um most interesting application of a i
for good
i i don't is there is that a like is
that a specific thing ai for
for good or is it just the concept of
using ai
for good i'm not sure
um
yeah
what would you advise to teenagers
really interested in agi or deep
learning research
um
well i don't i don't necessarily think
it's relevant that you're a teenager
learn anyone interested
probably learn to learn to program
and then just
dive into stuff it's probably most
interesting to dive into applications
and try to
code something yourself try to
understand other people's code
and from there you can go more a little
bit into the theory what's behind it
the most underrated skill in ml
huh what do i know um
i don't know
experience probably or maybe nowadays
the most underrated skills is knowing
how to use random forest and xgboost and
things like this uh
it's it's it's probably still
still
a lot of problems can be solved using
those things
um favorite and least favorite depiction
of ai and ml in fiction i
i've
i don't know
that's that's up to the up to the
fiction i don't have particular not too
much into fiction
um
what's your startup about it's legal
tech it's just uh processing legal
documents
um
is transformer in general better than a
cnn no in in general it's it's not
better in general both have their
strengths and weaknesses can someone buy
shares of your company
uh no not publicly
um but if you're not opposed to shady
backroom deals then uh
you know all up for it
um
have you ever fudged numbers for a paper
uh no but what what you
um what you do is you just try until you
get the number you want right you change
you change your method a bit you and so
on which is
you know
um
i mean that's research you ultimately
try to get your stuff to work but
there's definitely an element where you
put more work into your into optimizing
your method than the baselines so and
that's just what everyone does
um
internships during
phd good thing yeah definitely cool can
recommend
um tabs are illegal according to pep 8.
wow i didn't know
i i don't i don't like tabs
just personal opinion just
make your editor do
spaces uh instead of like i use the top
key but make your editor convert it to
spaces
um
[Music]
what are your favorite non-ml books i'm
i don't really i don't really have
um it also it changes
i
yeah
are ml research papers overrated i mean
some are some a lot of probably a lot
are probably
underrated so
[Music]
how many papers do you read per day
i like
however many however many come across
come in front of me
um really read
one
not super many but skim i skim a lot to
see if if i'm interested
four spaces or two spaces
i i don't i don't know i think i've set
my python to four and my
ecmascript to two
uh yeah are you scared of google
um
sure in in some way i'm i'm scared
of google
um
i was scared of google physical security
that definitely when i was there
they they sort of they laugh at you like
they smile at you you know the people
actually doing building security they
smile at you but they always see you as
like a bit of a threat even if you're if
you work there right they're like
i don't trust you
but yeah
are we in a simulation
no probably not like i i know it's uh
there's a convincing argument but
probably probably not
what was your dissertation on
adversarial examples
or or in general adversarial learning
um
not not world earth shattering
uh yeah
thought on nvidia's monopoly it's kind
of breaking up now
um
which is cool like amd's getting in
there there are their various things
like graphcore and and lambda
and
there's tpus and yeah
um
yeah it's it's sort of falling apart a
little bit though they'll probably still
make more money than they know what to
do with but
you know cool thing
um cool new things coming up in the
hardware
area
how do you do research without burning
out um you know look after yourself
um
just know yourself and how much how much
you can do and
you know
try to
try to not to to not fall into fomo too
much
why didn't you go for a post doc
i'm not a successful enough academic to
do
uh to become a professor so
doing a postdoc makes no sense for me
um yeah i just
like i haven't i haven't i haven't hyper
published papers during my uh phd i also
don't have any super impactful papers or
anything so
becoming a professor is not really
in it for me nor would i have
necessarily liked to do that um
how do i contact you about deep charge
my company is working on something
similar and we have a prototype in beta
as well a lot of users and firms
interested answer me you go to our
website
deepjudge.ai
it's ugly right now we're redesigning it
um
yeah there's a you can you can there's
there's an there's an email there's a
contact button there
otherwise otherwise i'm findable on on
twitter
if
if you want to step into that cesspool
could an ai create a game on the fly
um like graphic card creates visuals on
the fly yes uh there is already there's
work on procedural generation of like
game levels so that is
definitely
that is happening um
it's still
like whether or not the ai can come up
with a game like game rules or so on
i don't know but it can certainly um
invent
levels
uh of
games
i've i've seen i've seen even projects
where you can play these in real time so
um yeah
is ai overfunded
my sampling bias tells
me that it seems like there's no other
science except ai for funder's eye and
there's a bunch of others there's like
biology and
there's a bunch of tech i mean
blockchain
um
there's there's a lot of funding
going into ai
but
there's also a lot of stuff happening
right um there's a lot of a lot of cool
products that we haven't built yet
given the technologies that we have and
that are possible so
yeah
um
what's your favorite differential
equation
the the damped oscillator
probably
video idea neural networks in conway
game of life yeah why not
um
i thought about a neural network in
windows task manager but i i honestly
have no idea
how to achieve
that
in what order would you prefer work as a
research scientist deepmind nvidia
facebook google spotify opening a
microsoft
probably depends more on your on your
team within these companies than on the
actual company um
yeah so just select probably
your the most enjoyment will come from
selecting the people that you're going
to work with
rather than the company itself
have you tried doing ml with julia i
have not i don't know julia i know some
people like it but it seems like right
now there's no advantage in it's like a
parallel universe so
yeah no
are you a movie buff best sci-fi movie
no i'm i'm not much in i watch me movies
sometimes i'm not too much into
into movies
what's the coolest product in your
opinion um
the coolest product
i don't know
fire
the wheel
a steam engine i don't know
do you know 19 in french
what the number
disney
is that is an actual number i don't know
are you looking for interns
um
sure
i don't i don't know what
to do with them
so maybe not
uh yeah
no not not actively um
which programming languages are you
fluent on
uh
python
i used to be fluent in
java c plus plus
um
a bunch of others c certainly but
over time i've just not used them and
i've just used oh yeah of course uh um
yes so javascript i'm pretty fluent in
javascript as well
how to prevent hair from
how to prevent airfall do i look like i
have advice on that
um
favorite youtube channels um
so in general youtube uh
yeah pewds pewdiepie
obviously obviously um
yeah
no question
are you currently unemployed no i'm i'm
i'm very employed yeah
would you outsource c plus plus
optimization to scale a creation
sure if you can't do it
uh merch is coming is coming
um how many hours do you spend a day
during phd you mean on doing the phd
however many
you take um
do you recommend any advisor for a phd
at eth this is really a person like
advisor is a personal choice like this
there's no general recommendation for
all people
it's just
you know you just have to decide what's
what's best for you
are you on a switzerland right now yes
i'm i'm on a switzerland correct
um
yeah what's your opinion on elon musk
i like elon musk i i know like he over
promises stuff and and and and so on and
he gets a lot of hype going and and
whatnot
uh
but i'd rather have
i'd rather have have that like
yeah i'd rather have a world with with
elon than without um you know for all of
this over promising and whatnot um
he's also
doing really cool things so
yeah
thoughts on ml and bioinformatics
probably coming like probably
probably up and coming uh topic
yeah yeah
all right so i'm i'm gonna um
cut this now
i
as you can see it's dark ha ha
[Laughter]
um yeah
thanks uh so much for being here as i
said this wasn't really planned um
this it was for
100k i guess
maybe we can do amas more regularly but
thanks everyone for being here thanks
everyone for for subscribing or watching
uh videos it's a pleasure to make these
really and um
yeah i never would have i wouldn't have
guessed
that anyone will watch uh so this it's a
it's a huge compliment uh that you all
are here and uh i really i really thank
you um
yeah
thanks a lot and
i'll
i'll see you i guess